22 year old rookie right-hander ian
anderson starting for
brian snicker in the braves today an
outstanding coming-out party in his
rookie year
three and two era under two a whip just
over a run
and he's just the fourth atlanta rookie
to make a postseason start
he's got a lot on his shoulders today
hoping to pitch the braves into the
division series
comes upstairs with a fastball strikes
out a six-time all-star
and completes his first inning in his
postseason debut
in rather efficient manner and another
strikeout artist on the mound but a guy
that goes about it quite differently
from trevor bauer luis castillo the 27
year old changeup specialist
made his final regular season tune-up
start saturday in minneapolis
struck out four and didn't walk a batter
in a 7-3
loss and castillo makes his postseason
debut this afternoon
ozuna with a 0-5 opener yesterday
got him 98 just outside the strike zone
good enough to strike out ozuna for
route number two
well the reds had a couple of bases
loaded opportunities go by the wayside
yesterday
they have been gifted another one here
in the opportunity lines with tucker
barnhart
owen two with the bases loaded
on the ground for albies and the rookie
right-hander gets out of a bases loaded
jam
neither one of these teams have looked
very potent offensively over the last
day and a half
great bald strike three taken by
castillano sets number two for anderson
today
and a call strike three to fotto second
time anderson's rung him up today a one
two three
top of the third but for the reds they
are approaching a futility record
that they just as soon avoid they've
been shut out for 16
consecutive innings to start this
postseason the record is 20
innings held by the 1921 new york giants
a long time and a called strike three
taken by eugenio suarez that's
four on the day and three in a row for
ian anderson
mustacha strikes out it's four in a row
for anderson
anderson is on fire power fast boss
top of the zone and the change up
fourth strike out of the afternoon for
luis castillo now it's travis darno
banning with one out and the base is
empty
good night oh he's got it working now
five strikeouts for luis castillo
got him swinging three strikeouts in the
inning six on the afternoon for luis
castillo
galvez is aboard with one gone now for
tucker barnhart
elevated fastball strikes out tucker
barnhart
six for ian anderson today swinging a
miss by akiyama
seven strikeouts for the rookie
right-hander this afternoon
2-2 to swanson swung on and missed seven
strikeouts for each starter this
afternoon
here's mark cakus now
into center field base hit pitching has
certainly become the theme
not only today but in this series it's
ronda lacunia now with a runner at first
and two gone
four singles this afternoon for the
braves and acuna is responsible for two
of them a scoreless tie in the last of
the fifth
and acuna serves it into left that's
going to roll the wild
did they try it with riley they're going
to wave him around
he'll score without a play and atlanta's
on the board in the last of the 5th
[Applause]
it was the running start for reilly that
helped with a bad hamstring
in motion a 3-2 slider from castillo
not a good one a flat one and a long
awaited
first run of the day one-nothing brain
ian anderson back to work working with a
lead for the first time this afternoon
one nothing atlanta
there's a swing and a miss eight for ian
anderson today
two gun bases empty now for eugenio
suarez who has a single on his line
today
that was filthy flip the breaking ball
up around the eyes of suarez
six shutout innings a spectacular
postseason debut for rookie right-hander
ian anderson
here's the futility record that we've
got our eyes on and unfortunately for
the reds they're an inning away from
matching the 1921
giants with 20 consecutive
scoreless innings to begin a post season
two balls and no strikes to nick senzel
sliders good to right-handed hitters too
couple of strikeouts another impressive
relief ending by will
smith the great run producers you choke
up you put the ball in play
if the infield's playing back with a man
on third susan waldman would always say
just get the run
in like that marcelo
zuna has struck a two-run homer
three-nothing atlanta
the best fastball hitter in major league
baseball this year
almost 500 on that pitch and gets one
middle middle
95 miles an hour and he got all of it
adam duvall batting with the man on one
gone
bottom of the eighth three nothing
atlanta
that's into the corner and that one's
gone
adam duvall sends a two-run shot to left
and it's five-nothing atlanta and the
wheels are coming off now
i've all hit him yeah austin reilly's
hit by a pitch
one out remaining in the cincinnati reds
2020 season
and it'll be up to eugenio suarez
suarez lines to left and that'll do it
the atlanta braves have won their first
postseason series in 19 years
they're headed to the nlds